there are things which are right there
in front of us which we miss and I'll
quote my friend Eric Weinstein in saying
look
Einstein carried his luggage Freud
carried his luggage Marx carried his
luggage Martha Graham carried her
luggage etcetera Edison carried his
luggage all these geniuses carry their
luggage and not once before relatively
recently did it occur to anybody to put
a wheel on luggage and pull it and it
was right there waiting to be invented
for centuries so this is Erik Y Stein
yeah what do the wheels represent are
you basically saying that there's stuff
right in front of our eyes that once we
it just clicks we put the wheels in the
luggage a lot of things will fall into
place yes that I do I do and every day I
wake up and think why can't I be that
guy who was walking through the airport
what do you think it takes to be that
guy because when you said a lot of
really smart people carried their
luggage mm-hmm what just psychologically
speaking so Erik wants that is a good
example of a person who thinks outside
the box yes who resists almost
conventional thinking you're an example
of a person who by habit by psychology
by upbringing I don't know but resists
conventional thinking as well just by
Nature that's that's a compliment good
so what do you think it takes to do that
is that something you were just born
with I doubt it well I from my studying
some cases because I'm curious about
that obviously and just in a more
concrete way when I started out in
physics because I started a long way
from physics so it took me a long not a
long time but a lot of work to get to
study it and get into so I did wonder
about that and so I read the biographies
and in fact
with the autobiography of Einstein and
Newton and Galileo and all those all
those people and I think there's a
couple of things some of it is luck
being in the right place at the right
time
some of it is stubbornness and arrogance
which can easily go wrong yes and I know
I know
all of these are doorways if you go
through them slightly at the wrong speed
or in a wrong angle
there they're ways to fail but if you
somehow have the right look the right
confidence and arrogance caring I think
Einstein care to understand nature with
ferocity and commitment that exceeded
other people of his time so he asked
more stubborn questions he asked deeper
questions I think and there's a level of
ability and whether ability is born in
or can be developed at accenture which
can be developed like any of these
things like musical talent you mention
ego what's the role of ego in that
process confidence confidence but you do
in your own life if you found yourself
walking that nice edge of too much or
too little
so being overconfident and therefore
leading yourself astray are not
sufficiently confident to throw away the
conventional thinking of whatever the
theory of the day of theoretical physics
I don't know if I I mean I've
contributed where I've contributed
whether if I had had more confidence in
some things I would have gotten further
I don't know whether certainly hi I'm
sitting here at this moment with very
much my own approach to telling
everything
and I'm calm I'm happy about that
but on the other hand I know people
whose self-confidence vastly exceeds
mine and sometimes I think it's
justified and sometimes I think it's not
justified
you